trail assez de ces grands cinémas je
pense surtout que manuel valls a été le
premier ministre de françois hollande
avec un quinquennat catastrophique on a
l'impression que ce sont des images
comme ça qu'ils passent mais derrière il
ya un bilan tab 10 1 millions de
chômeurs ya mépris du peuple
il ya une soumission à bruxelles il ya
il ya une faillite
enfin le médiateur n'est pas légitime
pour vous mais en tout cas je la
combattrai parce que je veux combattre
ce socialisme qui a abîmé la france et
c'est insupportable pour tous les
français qui souffrent de voir ce jeu
politicien et cette femme elle a exprimé
le ridicule le ridicule de ces images
mais il ya aucun examen de conscience
chez zara
aucun examen de conscience et que la
gauche sera au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle mais je n'en sais rien
moi je me battrai pour un projet
différent et je crois que les français
aspirent
un grand coup de balai vrai ménage un
vrai ménage c'est pas parce que
l'emballage est différent que le contenu
est différent c'est le même contenu
c'est la même politique depuis 20 ans
qui a épuisé le pays
il est temps d'en changer est ce que
vous prendriez les mêmes mots que marine
le pen cette semaine mais ce sont des
doublures
oui bien sûr ce sont des doublures mais
je peux prendre les mêmes eaux que tous
les français
après ça veut pas dire que je veux
marine le pen justement je me présente
pour offrir un patriotisme vrai confirme
mais là mais ils ont le mot doublure par
rapport à tous les français l'om traîne
par rapport annuel malgré par rapport à
un autre
c'est certain fillon mais c'est des gens
qui gouvernent depuis 30 ans qui ont
fait exploser la dette qui ont été
responsables du matraquage fiscal qui
sont responsables de l'immigration
massive de la fiscalité bref le bilan
est accablant et on our cycle le jeu
politicien des primaires fait que on
veut faire passer pour 9 ce qui est
vieux alors alors de grâce parlons
d'autre chose alors